Nước lũ tranh vào Trung tâm thương mạnh của Ngoi Tô Tô Trương bây ở Trung Quốc.
Theo Tân Hoa Sá, Trung tâm khí tự trung quốc cho biết, bảo cá theo đang suy yếu thành hấp nhật nửi sau khi đồ bộ,
gây người lớn tại hơn mười tình thành từ ngày 1 tháng.
Mơ lớn gây gặp tại nhiều khu vực ở thượng hải, zang Tô và Chích Xan.
Tại zang Tô, Nước lũ tranh vào tình hâm một Trung tâm thương mạnh ở Chương Già Càng,
phá bữa cở cẩn sâu đồn và của nhiều tô dạng ngoài.
Các nhân viên phải trận cửa ngăn giống nước tranh vào.
Tại thượng hải, mười lắm trạng bước được bận hành đề xả nước bú ra xấu khoảng khổ,
giúp rằng nập khu vực nội đồ, thành phố gây nhận lượng mưa hơn 8,5mm trong 2mm dơ,
bước cao nhất trong hơn 1,5 năm.
Tại chết Xan, nơi tâm bảo đi qua, lực lượng cứ hộ được khi động dài cứu nhiều người mắt kẻ dưới giống lất,
nhiều tuyên đường gặp sâu, kây khu ý đồ dạng.
Dự báo mưa lần sẽ tiếp diễn đến ngày 12 tháng tảm tại chết Xan, Xan Tô, Hà Năm và Hà Bắc,
làm giá thang WI ke lúc luật và sát lở đất trên dịn dọng.
Cá hào là cơn bảo thứ mùi bà đồ bộ Trung Quốc trong năm nay, và cũng là cơn bảo mạnh nhất từ đầu năm.